[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what we come in sheepish we go
out uh
that's right welcome back to the break
room everybody uh we're thrilled that
you're here with us today on monday
august 8th we're coming at you live from
the new rockstars break room here at new
rockstar's headquarters the break room
of course the nerdy show that brings you
all the news that you want to keep up on
i was ready to do a hand gesture for
right here in our very own break room
right right here right here i know i i
screwed you up there john i'm doing well
yeah but you pointed to your crotch
i haven't taken a break there in years
but when i did it was very relaxing
you had to make it somehow that's right
that's right that's how you get hired at
new rock stars on a full-time basis
that's not how you do it don't even
think about it even do it on today's
show we're of course gonna be talking
about uh giancarlo esposito writing some
checks kevin feige can't cash we don't
know uh we also got some she-hulk
updates thor for news um
a wild redemption tommy we'll go into in
a moment here uh but joining me today on
this wonderful panel i've got erica
wusso
i've got john costa hey
i just want to point out my agents have
set up multiple meetings for me with
marvel and dc i can't talk about it a
lot yet but let's just say
things are cooking
things are cooking of course i'm zach
huddleston thrilled to be here with you
today now um
uh rumors that jessica's in costa rica i
don't know where that's coming from
she's absolutely not we buried her in
the backyard whoa
yeah but we buried him in the backyard
in the in the dirt from the sandman show
so she comes back every morning oh yeah
all right it's a very shallow grave also
if she's in costa rica no confirmation
on if she's at isla murada or wherever
the the jurassic park island is
it i don't know where i got laguna
miguel uh all i gotta say is yeah
everyone noticing my buffalo club shirt
you're right buffalo club forever this
is the club i was in in high school that
was uh people thought we were satan
worshipers i'm just kidding it's a
beautiful shirt from 26 shirts
charitable shirt company that does not
sponsor us but it's for charity so screw
up yeah thank you dell for this amazing
shirt and uh it's a good cause so look
up 26 shirts
thank you tommy yeah shout out to them
uh and uh speaking of good causes of
course we appreciate everybody that
throws a couple doubloons in the super
chat for us every day on friday
um i i'm sure it was none of you
currently watching yeah yeah but there
was a truly detestable group of humans
on friday working together in anarchy
colluding to debase and disgrace
particularly myself and tommy my mother
was watching that show she hasn't talked
to me since okay but i'm sure today
she's been calling me no no
but you're today's
and viewers are of the upstanding high
quality variety we had trash on friday
but guess what monday's trash day so
they went out in the morning and now all
we got is clean bins yes you're all a
bunch of squeaky clean bins so let's
talk redemptions it's hot chip summer
fam
and we're not talking the band or the
english slang for french fries okay
we're talking hot cheetos hot fritos hot
doritos
and hot pringles
so here's how it's going to work for
every 50 we raise that's right 5-0 a
little cheaper today we got to do we
have an inside did we forget that yes
it's right there we got it
we got an eight-sided guy
one of us or maybe two of us who knows
depending on how spicy no pun intended
we're feeling he's gonna roll the die
the corresponding die will go to a
corresponding spicy little treat and we
have that in focus can you see it you
can barely see it right up front we've
got a variety we've got eight we've got
eight different spicy chips ranging from
just not your standard flamin hot
cheetos to the previously consumed
absolutely disgusting um
ghost peppers we've got a we've got a
carolina reaper chip we've got scorching
hot pringles i've never even heard of
these so here's where it is every 50
one or two of us are gonna roll the dice
i don't know why i keep making more
people getting i just want to eat spicy
stuff we lowered the dollar it makes me
so miserable though i it actually
creates an urgency in me and my brain
cells fire faster i feel like my
theories and points are better so here's
what here's where it gets
extra spicy spicy
spicy i thought you might be having a
stroke guys we're also on stroke watch
okay make sure every few minutes asked
me to smile and put my arms above my
head out here you got it
okay we're good yeah uh okay we're good
uh
if someone donates 50 or more five zero
or more that will trigger the hell dice
okay that turns the dice into a satanic
artifact and that means whatever chip we
land on we will then dip either into a
giardiniera hot giardiniera pepper
spread or a jar of jalapeno so if you
really want to make sure that we are
hurting from our sweet mouse to our down
south
go ahead and hit the super chat today
okay from our mouth holes to our south
pole
also this is a terrible idea uh please
do not force any of us to do this but i
do want to call out um our friend uh
suave yeah who um
donated in costa rican currency yeah and
said i love how often you guys talk
about costa rica when is the live break
room happening down there pura vida my
man we would love to do a live one from
costa rica you're kidding me also let us
know is there a costa rica comic-con is
there a convention we can go down there
for you know it might take a few shekels
out of out of our out of our bills
because let's be honest the women of
costa rica have been clamoring for me to
come down there for a while i don't know
if it's because they want to they want
to harvest me for my seed or what but
i'll do it i'll do it
do it with your like little height
differences
what a little stranger
i get up to no good
we gladly eat all the spicy chips on
this table for a costa rican uh vacay
that's right but thank you also
charlie836 oh gregor
graveyard3503 thank you for your super
chats um but john told me that uh he
can't handle spicy food so if you want
to make chocolate sauce right genuinely
we have what we have we have layered
here we all saw how i reacted to spicy
food that's a nervous breakdown john
says that he is not good at spicy food
eric says he likes spicy food but you
know keep it reasonable and zach let's
just say you're going to want to see
zach on the spices something new happens
i mean this this
this porcelain visage turns
a certain shade of crimson you want to
turn zack into the kool-aid man just
hey hey hey uh but first we must do the
headline
let's go
headlines okay uh first he does a good
job of staying in the headlines uh king
of the twitter q a james gunn revealed
that he translates group lines in some
scripts he tweeted out the quote
in the scripts for crew and cast that
don't understand groot it says i am
groot but i also have scripts available
for those who understand groot with the
translations in them and i want to
contextualize because when i first read
that quote i thought it was said by an
insane person
what he means is if in the mcu canon
their character understands groups
that he writes the lines and i guess
they're a guardian right right but if
they but but he said that can only be
accomplished through spending and
bonding with groot over a series of
years so he said that there were some
guardians that initially didn't
understand him but now at this point all
of the guardians okay all right james
gunn keeping it k fave i appreciate you
and it looks like oh
a couple of folks are pushing us over
the boundary here so in a moment here
one of us will be rolling the dice and
eating a disgusting hot chick oh no
jessica clements in the chat
love for johnny c jessica we miss you
they got they got good wife right down
there in costa rica john and zach look
people are
no notes for john and zach eric and i
evidently chopped freaking liberal yep
that's right uh one more more headline
before uh the chip journey commences um
speaking with the hollywood reporter the
writer of thor for uh
jennifer cayton robinson explained that
the pivotal scene uh that kind of
flashed back on the history of the
relationship between thor and jane um
that was added in reshoots it was taiko
ytd's idea but that was after principal
photography had finished they went back
and shot that and added it in we were
talking about this before i loved
that sequence one of my favorite scenes
in the movie kind of shocking that they
didn't include it in the first place but
you know it's funny because we were
sitting there in the theater zach and i
watched it together because we're an old
married couple and um
it was shot so differently from
everything else yeah anyway it looked
like they just sort of got you know
chris hemsworth and natalie portman
together one afternoon we're like we're
just gonna i got my dslr out we're just
gonna shoot this quick you know one two
three yeah it's mostly it's like all
like in an apartment and maybe like a
restaurant yeah mostly like handhelds
yeah yeah it was really no cgi yeah it's
a cheap reshoot but then but then
there's a really important part in that
scene right which is when thor sort of
like looks at mjolnir and says like
protect her with with yeah you know
at all
yeah unfortunately del mar domino has
triggered the hell died
now the top two in the poll are both
going to be rolling the hell down
yeah [ __ ] on you
separate hell dies though so johnny you
know what you're taking it away you know
what del mar they love watching me
suffer i know this del mar uh character
we actually um i have delmar's head shot
oh wow real quick that we printed out
beforehand right you're trash now
it's a dinosaur you're a trash bag
delmar shame
del mar's revenge because zach you and i
are both rolling the hell down oh okay
god we got another one no i think we
offer this oh all right i should all
just do it oh no shira s shame on your
shirt
okay
or into some pickled okay what do i got
going here
oh no tommy oh no it's a carolina reaper
tommy
all right here we go
right give me something hot and tasty
please
okay the five is um i think it's the
blue heat tacky we're going to get a
close-up on this beautiful garlic
oh look at that i actually love
jardinero but this is not what it was
meant
why did i do this on episodes when i'm
on
eric recoiled from the opening of that
bag
uh can i have a spoon one of the spoons
from up there okay yeah good idea this
is not okay so i've got that yeah cheeto
is not really a dippable okay i've got a
got a flamin hot dorito lamone with a
couple of pickled uh jalapenos on there
and i've got a tasting of
a reaper pepper cheeto with some hot
gardener oh you went in all right cheers
to keep it spicy oh god no
immediate no
no
no no no drink your water
we've got it we've got a dog showing up
not knowing what he's getting into here
oh my god mine's you know what the
pickled jalapenos it gives you a sweet
pickled opinion
i think tommy definitely lost now john
what's your record on the online
mine started sweet but the heat is
coming and i think in about 30 to 40
seconds i'm going to be on the floor and
now again the heat is coming eric was
eating the fascinating blue heat taki
now now if you know anything about
chemistry right yeah blue flames are
like the hottest possible flame the
hardest hottest part of the fire let
yeah what do you what's your report on
the blue the blue heat tacky there it's
definitely killing the back quadrant of
the right side of my tongue
but uh it tastes good it tastes good i'm
not crying yet but we'll see what
happens when we get to manchester i do
feel the sweat like moving to the front
of my face
i have a point
i have a salient point
the tail on these is not as bad okay as
the as the pocky chips
i'm now
the front of my mouth
is forever changed
but the back is kind of recovered the
back is uncomfortable
but kind of recovering that's not an
encouragement for any of you to give a
single dollar board
stop the insanity you're all disgusting
you got
hey i ain't afraid that's tramping
our hr person decide to be in office
today
we should lady and [ __ ] a cheeto to be
honest that's the most satisfying i feel
like i got off the easiest mine was
tasty and not at all
a lime uh pepper uh doritos with a
little uh pickled jalapeno what does
this show about
what's
back to the headlines uh one other thing
from um uh the writer of thor 11 thunder
uh she said that uh bringing back loki
in the film was off the table because
he's off doing his own thing in loki
land i like that she kind of made a
contest i know she didn't purposely do
it but in print it seems incredibly
condescending she's like he's in loki
land which is a little different
again i i loved it i love thor 11
thunder love the loki series
i still wanted a little cameo at least a
little bit maybe maybe it's better
because if he just showed up for 10
seconds of screen time it would have
felt hollow we would have wanted him to
be an important part of the storyline
but the perfect place for him would have
been in that flashback yeah
right uh if he's driving a wedge between
jane and thor but you know tycha killed
uh or i guess taika didn't kill loki but
you know it feels like that story
yeah it sort of feels like that story
had sort of concluded and you gotta send
them off on a new yeah and this though
we were traveling to different planets
we were not time traveling we were not
dimensional traveling yeah just down
memory lane though
hank's literally biting my ankles not
fighting like
like not not i don't want to scare
anyone from the aspc it would have been
funny to see loki real quick in that
relationship flashback as like jane is
doing stuff around the house and thor is
looking suspiciously and like grabs jane
by the scruff and it turns out to be
total low-key there's a dog has probably
gotten into the pockets and is uh insane
uh speaking of thor 11 thunder taika
white tt was at a screening
and he let it slip that marvel has a
hercules slash greek gods project in
development so now that's interesting
because that does not sound like
hercules is going to show up in thor 5.
right well that there is even a thor 5
in development i think we have a clip of
this uh he sort of was like i didn't
even know that hercules was a marvel
character before doing this movie do we
have that i don't remember
and then
we're going to introduce hercules and
that
made no sense to me i didn't know
[Music]
hercules in the film well yeah cause we
saw the concept art of zeus uh or
russell crowe originally gonna be satan
and then i wonder if they were just sort
of like we want to do this greek gods
thing so can we just kind of tee them up
here real fast interesting i have
already developed indigestion from that
okay
i can't wait to make out with you later
uh oh boy your inside matches the devil
on your sprocket
um via the she-hulk twitter account we
got our best look at daredevil yet and
we actually we have this asset as well
to show okay
oh a little head shot there
yeah it does seem like they're just sort
of sticking with the
netflix version of this character as
much as they can
right it makes sense same actor yeah
right yeah different dlc skin you know
the yellow yeah
yeah there's a little bit of the yellow
on the arms but but you know when they
brought some of these characters from
the sony
spider-man universe into you know they
totally redid the design for electro
yeah um so i guess i was i was sort of
like oh maybe they'll just kind of
change costume stuff here and there and
i guess they do but
and it'll be fascinating to see what
else they continue versus change right
from the the netflix series yeah yeah
how much of that is will be canon going
pin sort of had a different look ish
right in the in the netflix stuff i know
vincent d'onofrio was like oh this is an
opportunity to just sort of like try
some new stuff out with this character
it's been a couple years people change
church
he's got the money people go casual um
yeah uh oh god okay
you know what you know what delmar
domino this is an act of aggression okay
and it will not stand and now i uh i
will
i will uh roll on behalf of my my cast
here i don't want to subject before
tommy could push him over the edge oh
now i keep looking out that's a two are
you falling on a sword here that's
that's just uh
for 50 we got to go i'm going to
participate yeah i want some more chips
all right i rolled a four what is that
all right i am uh if someone donates a
hundred dollars flat
i'll put a handful of these things in my
mouth whatever i wrote
tommy last time you had to drive to the
airport where you were yeah that is true
that is true i did drive to lax
immediately after the party's started oh
no anybody's ready
let me get it let me get a jalapeno oh
yeah oh yeah yeah these things are
actually nice
i should have done a candy jalapeno this
time no oh it's fine
with me after the show i know they're
great we'll fight over it all right
everyone cheers
oh god oh no oh that one's horrible
the chip is really good
it's the jardin era that gets you
oh and you think there's there's like 11
year olds that eat this stuff
like on a daily basis what's wrong with
your freaks whoo
i feel it in the back of my throat you
know what i said there were a bunch of
clean bins today i lied
trash bags all over the trash bags i
guess the garbage man must have taken
today off was there a strike
because i see nothing but trash in there
jalapeno
feels like it took a lighter to the
dangly thing in the back of my throat
the dangling thing what is in the jordan
era
good god it is it is listed as hot okay
it's marconi original chicago that is
the stuff that they carry in every sort
of deli in chicago um okay uh oh we got
another uh we got a great um
she-hulk spot
that um focused on what looked like a
support group that emil blonsky is
running
yes and so we see
some interesting characters in that shot
um
uh she hulk is there in she-hulk form
some guy with horns and kind of like an
interesting looking face
yeah it's really weird we saw in
previous trailers that there was sort of
like this like blond ski self-help type
book coming out we don't really know the
timeline of this show we've got some
smart hulk but we've also got some
regular bruises
we were speculating because a lot of the
blonsky shots we've seen previously he's
in some kind of holding cell seems like
she's maybe representing him does that
kind of mean she wins she gets him out
and then in out in the gym you know in
the open world or whatever outside of
prison he's running this support group
or something like that seems like a
totally reformed guy or do you think is
there a chance that that scene is set
inside
super praise that's possible he's just a
more chill spot within supervisor the
dndc was like have some blankets have
some ghosts really chill out what still
interests me the most is um
uh
both blomsky and uh bruce now it seems
like can kind of go back and forth
between abomination and blonsky and hulk
and smart hulk i wonder if blonsky
doesn't have as much control over it and
that's why he'll kind of have a more
unpredictable nature now i just want to
say i was inspired by someone in the
chat i've made a decision uh-oh
if we cross 400 oh no no i'll put one of
each in my mouth oh at the same time one
bite one chomp okay i love it
i'll join you in that i've gotten off so
easy i feel bad now i did not get off
easy friday no
this uh this table currently looks like
we're a bunch of like college stoners i
accidentally bought all the hot versions
hey you guys are back to nerd chat yeah
what's up my name is tv stunner
these are my boys all of their names end
in 69.
we just finished two hours of mario kart
the boys are taking a break from a cod
uh a cod sequence we went in sequence
out of style you know i don't game
we've got since the super chats have
come in hot and fast we're ten dollars
away from just a normal one-person roll
to dice and yes we're going to do that
at every 50 yeah yeah thank you for
reminding us there john um oh uh so this
is an interesting we've got two
there's been a series of uh actors
saying interesting things at conventions
and different events so this was kind of
this has been a roller coaster ride over
the last like 72 hours so rosario dawson
talented actress ahsoka tana herself uh
oh my god
six six seven zero
shame on you shame on you six seven zero
uh
what a generous trash bag you want what
a ch what a giant garbage show if you're
a dumpster yeah
um so here i'll finish this headline and
then we will all partake in some just
gonna do two each now uh that sounds
right um so rosario dawson's at c2e2
uh in chicago at a con there and and she
said should this interesting quote
basically saying
oh i'm excited for the punisher to come
back
um i haven't heard an official thing but
a fan told me it's coming back and i
want to be involved with that because
that was the only netflix series i was
not in she was in the defenders and in
the other series but she didn't appear
on
uh the punisher specifically yeah she
really threw people into a tizzy because
she didn't say the fan part at the event
she was just sort of like i didn't know
this was announced but i heard punishers
coming back and everyone was like late
oh this is how it comes out because
again there's been no talk of bringing
back um
frank
john barenthal's uh portrayal of
punisher though people have been
mentioning it now that we're getting
charlie crosstalk
um
um and then she walked it back and she
was like i can't be trusted clearly just
some fan at this convention bumped into
her i was like are you excited for
punisher to come back she took that to
be like well has it been announced
because you know what she hasn't been
watching the break room uh
rosario if you are watching our show
every day you would know what's
officially been announced versus what's
just being speculated let us be your
fans that's right come on the show your
friends come on the show rosario rosario
all of us
uh i do want to play someone said they
feel sorry for our toilets tomorrow baby
this is a fast this is this is a carpool
lane okay
this will be dealt with tonight uh give
me that dice i'm gonna roll put it in it
might not make it to the episode we'll
find out all right okay
first here
six okay oh wasn't that that was fun
that was the the flamingo
flaming hot chocolate bit of a reprieve
for you oh i got a five oh oh i think
that might be the um
i think that might be the pocky ghost
pepper okay
my good luck my good left hand
this is a handful i rolled another four
i'm doing lebron six seven zero you sick
maniac this is for you
tommy good god i got a three
will you have me a spoon there
i'm gonna really load up okay now these
these are the things that made uh
jessica and tommy really those are all
apart let me try these things eric what
you'll find is that jordan era is the
worst
solidarity what do you guys do a little
scoop dude
put it on here like a wedding band oh
god
oh no it begins oh it's a slow it's a
slow creep it's like going up the roller
coaster i hear the clicking underneath
the wheels no uh-uh no it's in my nose
no it's in my nose get a napkin
quick
um
this is a nightmare
why do we do this god damn we do it
because we were born to do it
willy wonka was born to be a candy man
you look like you were born to be a
wanderer why does chicago like these um
let's do a shot of a lord next time yeah
[ __ ] it oh yeah if you're in chicago
sorry i said the f word i know but you
know we don't do that anymore uh
send us a bottle of the lord this
weekend yeah tommy and i are both gonna
be in chicago i can't buy
something has happened to the inside of
my mouth where that handful of those
spicy cheetos
it hurt
but i've been too hurt now like i'm used
to it i was like on the other side
he's on the other side
john's got to take a break while doing a
press trip or a bullet train um joker
actress zazie beats told the hollywood
reporter that joker 2 being a musical
makes sense
which is interesting because for a lot
of other people it seems like pretty far
afield
she was quoted as saying i love musicals
and i think of them as the characters
are feeling and experiencing so much
oh my god the burps are even worse
okay now i regret what i said because
it's moving down my throat
and i don't think i'm okay the
characters are feeling and experiencing
so much that they can only sing and
dance about it whether in sorrow or
enjoy and so i can see arthur who's
feeling and experiencing so much dancing
and singing about it first off credit to
zazee beats
what a composed yeah and like perfectly
formed thought that is to be asked like
on a red carpet and to deliver like a
perfect paragraph yeah explaining uh her
thoughts uh that she's good she's very
good she's wondering is this something
that she fired off to todd phillips and
was like musical what the [ __ ] and he
was like here's what i think is the
practice
perfect representation well we were
talking
she does not pull a thirsty thespian in
that moment she put me in the movie and
we were saying like what are the odds
her character shows up like it you know
she was not kind of
she was technically a big part of joker
but like not in the canon of the movie
right a lot of that was taking place in
arthur's right brain and so it wouldn't
make sense to like oh they are
continuing a relationship in the second
phase we've heard this movie is going to
take place a lot in arkham asylum where
we assume
unless she's having some kind of weird
delusions um or she's a nurse or orderly
oh
that's a great take oh throw it but do
you think i mean she does kind of like
doesn't they have a weird moment where
he's in her apartment right right yes
but like in a stalker way yeah yeah so
i'm saying like do you think but she
sees him in the apartment right yeah so
do you think that
after that i mean this is just me this
is real world not joker world
that he would go that she would then get
a job at a a institution for the
criminally insane
like maybe maybe she's like oh wow this
was this really affected me i want to
help i want to help these people uh the
storm virgil thank you why do people
like to torture my sweet sweet boys
i appreciate the sentiment but
technically you're yeah as john said
you're trash oh that's what he's trying
to say ncc uh long time watcher first
time super chatter why today ncc that's
the best outfit you know
you down with ncc no you're garbage
okay
uh you're a fan of 90s rap that that
really hit um okay on his hollywood
babylon podcast kevin smith uh revealed
that he too fell victim to all these
recent crazy warner brothers discovery
um content cancellations his uh dc
strange adventures series on hbo max has
been cancelled now we think this was
like early stages of development this
has been it was announced a while ago
and
so early in development i didn't even
know about that this was not at the tip
of any of our times right but uh strange
adventures is a dc comic that's kind of
a um
uh this series at least was being
pitched as like a little bit of a black
mirror but for superheroes in the dc
universe kind of a thing like um
anthology series a lot of like maybe
like dark twisted kind of stuff going on
but it's no more damn i i do like that
dc is like we're to take a step back
we're going to refocus we are in we have
our hands in too many cookie jars we're
just going to kind of pick one or two
things i i love that but or but at the
same time i am like oh they're taking
away things that i thought were going to
be really yes perhaps the strangest
adventure
is death
john oliver made a joke on his show last
night that um he like joking welcoming
his new bosses and being like can't help
but think you're uh
selling off my channel for the insurance
money
we're setting it on fire for the
insurance money and yeah we hope again
we're hopeful here we're taking the
stance and we're hopeful for the future
of dc though it's strange right now
speaking of dc idris elba teased a big
return to dc in an interview with
fandango and rotten tomatoes reporter
eric davis uh he was talking about it
he's doing the press tour for an
unrelated film called beast but he said
uh he's got a really big thing cooking
for dc right now uh can i say this is a
new avenue
into the thirsty
category because he's already been cast
we've talked about this
but then you unspecifically tease that
you have a huge thing coming which saves
you from being criticized by your bosses
but also paints them into a bit of a
corner you can't cancel this can't
cancel them
you can't cancel what can't die well and
actually he appears to be
there seems to be two corners of dce
films that are kind of safe yeah and
that's matt reeves projects and james
gunn projects yeah and so if he's
getting uh a spin-off from the suicide
squad like john cena got with peacemaker
maybe that is safe well and i you know
james gunn has been talking about he's
doing another sort of show in that
universe but he said it's not the amanda
waller show that's been talking about
wouldn't this be a perfect candidate
yeah he's just like oh peacemaker was
super successful let's just do the other
side of that sort of war and we'll do
one for idris
i've avoided saying that character's
name is it dead shot or kill shot
there's a shot dead no it's dead shot
it's that shot okay
okay thank you
what was what was the will smith's
character's name from the first two
sentences
so much they're so similar uh blood
sports
okay thank you thank you
yes
you know what else is
there you go oh we hit four hundred i
gotta try this reaper right now yeah
give me your money
oh all of a sudden you know i'm gonna do
them all i said i would i'm really just
gonna try all the ones out of the
segments up next
yeah we're gonna get john in good shape
for his discussion segment pass these
around if anyone wants one of these oh
yeah well i mean i don't want one but i
said i'd eat one
okay oh sorry yep it's a smartest board
of sand up here i can't ignore this i
did have one of those but i'll try
another one i can't ignore these blue
oh we haven't even got the scorching hot
pringles yeah but you know what's going
to happen once we pop them the fun part
this is criminal this is wrong
you guys did this to us i want you to
know you did this all right each and
every one of you
i have an eye thing and i'm so worried
though oh don't touch your face don't
don't don't don't touch it touch your
face oh these blue heat things are
they're good
they're good and aggressive yeah
i like them i'm bringing it up there's
how i like my ladies camera four
number four where are you where's my
hand
look at this abomination everything is
tommy
my shits are gonna be so red tonight
tommy it was it was positive vibes
monday and it's still positive vibes
positive vibes this is vile i'm chasing
it i'm chasing it with a jalapeno oh my
god
i can't do it all in my mouth at the
same time so i'm going two bites yeah
maybe let's try a couple of these here
we go
oh doggie
a lot of crunching into the microphone
mm-hmm love that
i love that also an underrated part of
this challenge just the sodium load that
we're all in taking i'm i can feel my
fingers starting to swell oh yeah okay
all right
the flaming doritos lime
has a really good like citrus they're
nice they're actually very nice some of
these things are tasty mm-hmm i would
consider adding them to my snacks
no no the cumulative effect of all of
them is uh brutal here's what i'll say
the pocky one cuts through everything so
aggressively yes oh man
a bargain one is a heat-seeking missile
what are you doing with the jalapenos
i'm just eating them
right
oh uh also via eric davis's twitter
account
uh we got an interesting little tidbit
tommy might be done
he's never gonna be the same let's be
honest um
uh about gal gadot we got some
interesting news so now this is like
it's kind of third hand we think this
was like a different person reporting
uh uh via eric davis that um
when asked if she was gonna be in at
least one more movie as wonder woman she
said oh yeah for sure she's in a couple
other movies and i'm not going to spoil
them
which i just kind of did
wow
yeah so we're assuming well and possibly
also aquaman two maybe she even shows up
in black adam maybe maybe oh maybe yeah
um yeah but interesting a couple other
movies and it's already confirmed so
these could be movies that are already
shot uh maybe a shazam maybe she's
featured heavily in batgirl
featuring beverly and bad girl
nobody tell her
tommy
tommy needs to cool off
putting my cool i'm sitting in the old
spice cool zone
okay so uh it took us a little while to
get here but uh the
the topic from our thumbnail our buddy
jean carlo esposito
um ruler of all ip at this point right
like you name a cool project he's
showing up the boys the mandalorian uh
better call of course
the new do the right thing series i
don't
but he's been talking a lot lately he's
a great interview he loves to drop fun
quotes into interviews and he's been
saying lately that he's been in talks
with kevin feige
about taking on multiple
yeah
and uh
do you think she could finish out the
show he like name dropped a bunch of
characters can any of you
can any of you awful trash bags out
there who are forces to eat these bad
snacks can any of you sub in for tommy
he if if ever he needed a tag team
partner to
uh i do some work for him my mouth
doesn't even hurt anymore it just feels
like a separate thing for my body
feels i feel
i feel high
yes i feel like an endorphin rise yeah
it's like a near-death experience i got
a replacement right here
okay um oh oh no
this is my favorite here we go oh eric
voss headshot making an appearance on
the channel um camera four
okay i like that i walked close to
camera four to get a close-up before
when it just could have shown me
yeah you could have just held it up in
front of your face um but so he teased
four characters he specifically named
them at an event here we have the video
oh we have the video let's play the
video there's the talk of magneto
[Applause]
[Music]
there has been talk of who else are they
talking about over there
and there is
professor x
[Applause]
pick one pick one
i'm gonna go for something that is a
little bit different
i'm gonna go and put it out in the
universe that it is
professor x
okay i can do it again wow
what a moment oh my god we thought that
club was ending before it did um now
we've been talking about this all day
now the fan casting of him as professor
x has been out there for a while
i would say he's been fantastic in all
these roles who he's been fantastic
oh yeah i want to talk about one world
specifically
he's at a live event not everybody's as
perfectly composed as daisy beats okay
so like he's just rattling things off
he's even having to ask whoever else was
on stage there with him for some help
and he one of the things he says is dr
freeze oh love love classic comic
character
now there is vincent vaughn 3.
there is no marvel character or dc
character for that matter named dr
freeze there's a dc character named mr
freeze he would not be talking to kevin
feige about that no presumably so yes
who do we think that
i i just had some of the most painful
burps in my life i apologize to you the
audience no you they did this that's
true that's right that's what you get um
i reward you the audience with these
toxic burps
so obviously he'd be a great pick for
any of these roles but like i'm
fascinated what do you think he meant to
say when he said doctor
my gut right tells me that giancarlo
esposito
he's a very well respected actor taking
meetings all over the place probably
just like walked into some dude at dc's
office and they were like
hey we're gonna we're doing these batman
movies there's this character mr freeze
that we really like you for so you think
he's good i think he's got two meanings
he just
pretty similar to gustavo frank he would
be
kind of right there with that tone of
how mr freeze is and batman the animated
series anyway like yeah kind of like how
is he with a punt
ice cold yeah trying to put you on
icebergs joke's always chill
um
yeah so i i don't know i again
we've talked before he gets a standing
cultivation no that's not a pun it's not
a pun
that's just you're uh putting cold into
another word um stop consulting me
stop critic holding me no
ah
everyone's a
critical
uh
[Laughter]
this is like a chicken egg situation
tommy's brain is currently 40 spicy dust
this is what happens when you sleep 17
hours a night now okay well
the one thing i'll say is like
my this is my far field theory
speculation that maybe he didn't mean to
say doctor
and he got confused with the freeze and
and we were saying like oh well but he
also said doctor doom so the doctor was
not in reference to dr jim but eric you
actually pointed out there's some other
well-known doctors in the mcu there are
um yes
popular marvel character yeah uh but
also reed richards is the doctor
technically yeah uh as is i guess tony
stark oh who's the other person
dr bruce yes so
uh our favorite juan carlo esposito
could play a variant or a multiverse
version of one doctor researchers the
storm's a doctor as well right
[Music]
hey john
how much does a polar bear weigh i don't
know enough to break the ice hey dr
freeze how are you that's pretty good
okay well it's real casual dr freeze
right there i think you're welcome i i
love the idea just eric saying that in
the office earlier of like ginger
esposito playing a reed richards and i
know we've all got our hearts set in our
mindset on john krasinski right now but
like what if you could do it a new take
on the fantastic four maybe it is a
multiversal thing where it's like it
could be a multi-generational thing
they're still the first family but maybe
he's the dad of a sue storm or a uh ben
graham or something like that right or
uncle or something and a lot of people
were saying you know
now that uh
jonathan majors is playing uh kang
who is
technically like a super
far on descendant of reed richards like
they'll probably cast a black reed
richards who knows like they're so far
of a descendant that like you know it
doesn't really matter i guess but like
would be a fun choice to have like an
older different uh richards in the mcu
yeah uh someone did point out that the
biggest factor we've forgotten is doctor
marco morbius
it's morgan's house wait they're already
gonna recast
i don't know if is john carlos mosino
black
he's italian and i don't know how he
identifies he's like
yeah yeah yeah yes maybe
in there somewhere maybe yeah i don't
know he identified there's an interview
from him uh after doing the right thing
when he's young it's amazing because
it's like he's like 20 something yeah
and he looks great and he talks about
how identification he's obviously looks
like well he just looks you see like
this stuff like he's like older gian
carlos you know and he's like just like
a cool looking kid like you're like all
right everybody's young once but anyway
he identifies as that for latino in that
interview anyway
thank you tommy thank you tommy that's
race relations with tommy
that's what the folks are tuning in for
hot chips and uh identifying people's
racial backgrounds listen if there's one
thing i can do from a mile away to tell
you what race someone is daddy i gotta
move on
back to my black theory
yeah
please be quiet
[Laughter]
you know what color i'm comfortable
talking about
it's green yes
it's easy being green in its athletic
greens specifically their ag-1 formula
let me tell you something
no don't let all these chips fool you
your boy's been eating good the last
couple of weeks i've witnessed that i've
been working with a weight loss and
nutrition specialist i've been
integrating a little exercise into my
diet but one thing i had taken off a
little bit of exercise listen i'm not
i'm not gonna be an angel your diet
romeo wasn't built in a day and this
body is gonna be built over us by a
series of doctors over years anyhow
i had taken the ag-1 out of my diet
because i was rebuilding and working on
a very specific meal plan well that's
over and now it's time for this fish to
swim out on his own without his mommy
fish attaching him to her mommy fish
nipples anyway
ag-1 i'm back on the sauce yeah i'm back
on the ag-1 and i'm already feeling the
effects but
getting back on the ag-1 got me
motivated
i said all right i'm trying ag-1 again
i'm back on the athletic greens let me
try something new so today after this
real talk my friend and i are going on a
hike hey this is not a body built by
hiking but it could be and it's
certainly helped by aging ones there's
no need for a completely complicated
cocktail of costly concoctions
just a little cup of age in your tummy
and you'll get you feeling healthy
wealthy and wise baby the three tenets
of a better lifestyle be healthy be
wealthy be wise call me or at least
it will be like a convenient insurance
to make sure you get all the good stuff
you need one day which is important
especially if you're trying to lose
weight yes you eliminate a lot of things
from your diet and you may not be
getting the nutrients you need something
like this bingo bango fun as i like to
say it to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs which i
cannot recommend highly enough zach and
i will be traveling later this week and
you know i'm gonna ask my man for some
travel packs all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
break room again that is athletic
greens.com
break room important
that you use our code because it helps
us yes so just type in some random code
for some jabroni's at another channel or
even on this channel you type in break
room you guys ever do that when you're
like looking to buy us something and
you're just like oh let me just type in
a bunch of random podcasts all the time
so just try break room everywhere
everywhere
sometimes i just type in letters anyway
just to feel something take ownership
over your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance yes
thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring us all week we appreciate
them they help us bring this show to you
somebody's got to pay for all these
discussions and i got to say without
those athletic greens this mouth would
be in way worse shape
go down that hatch um i mean from the
hot cheeks from the hot chips hot chips
yes uh not anything else well uh not the
abuse some would say you know when you
add it into your diet athletic grains
becomes
mandatory whoa
speaking of mandatory
it's time for mandatory fun wow
it's the weekly daily segment once a
week every day i bring
three of my best friends and
one secret enemy oh into the office
there's like four of us here there's a
dog oh okay
hank is one of my best friends so figure
that out i bring my three best friends
in for a little bit of non-optional joy
with me
as if this hasn't already been so
enjoyable i have noticed you guys have
stopped making us eat hot stuff which we
greatly appreciate thank you for
stopping giving normally we'd get in
trouble for that the bosses would say
stop encouraging them to not super chat
but my mouth can't take no more i'm kind
of mad this segment would be better if
you were dying oh no okay i just want to
put that out there but we are 31 away
from that
21 20 30 i would say if we have 500.
i don't think anybody should do this
please just watch the show
don't donate any more money okay because
if we hit 500
i will chubby bunny
with the packy chips oh god knows that i
will you can't do that in my mouth you
can't do there's so much spice so much
too much that's too much you're
responsible for you to do that's why
they should not they won't do it not
this group of people people is too kind
hit the graphic again
that's right it's mandatory fun you
thought the graphic was twice but you
know what would be nice
hit the image of she-hulk and daredevil
vanessa
you should be sorry
come on
all right understandably emotions are
high in nerd dumb right now
emotions are high at the stable as well
some of us are actually higher stable
from the hot chips they keep coming up
yeah that's the problem when you eat
these
they stay with you for a minute yeah
this is why women live longer i i gotta
agree yeah i think so yeah there's a
long list of reasons why i hope they get
longer no that's a good point uh i also
mentor i'm actually curious about trains
in their tracks
anyway
just ask my grandpa you can't ask him
because he's dead
from a train crash we're all callers and
we haven't decided understandably
emotions are high endured them right now
batgirl is not coming out folks yeah no
matter how hard you call for her girl no
she's gone she's on the shelf now simulu
our man come on the break come on the
show he's making joke tweets about
shanghai holiday special getting
scrapped do we have this tweet to pull
out
yes there it is i'm sorry to inform you
guys that disney has decided to scrap
the shanxi howdy special due to quality
control concerns i'd already filmed the
entire thing i even designed an all
gingerbread tallow
rip shanxi the legend of the ten
golden rings
four katie snark three abominations
to
the
that's a different property
uh
the fist is from the daredevil what no
yeah right yeah yeah the hand the hand
yeah the fist is uh
very different corner
[Music]
not those pocky yeah well when i was
thinking you were talking about the
toxic oh taco
no i'm doing i'm going to do a mouthful
of these shame on you
and shame on everybody that encouraged
him okay my death is on all of your
hands and i'll do a hell roll because we
crossed over the thing i'll do a hell
roll oh
hell roll
oh god i gotta need i got the cheetos
again
[ __ ] cheese freaking cheetos sorry i
love my ruffles
i love my raffles i love them
which one is the stick oh
chicks is the fun fritos there right i
think it's like dealer's choice
at this point i think it's just grab
whatever hot thing you want this sucks
it's like the oil is spicy too i don't
know
oh
spicy oil even like my lips hurt already
oh no
throw in some extra blue spoon man it's
pretty fun this is grape
this is great it's good
oh my god
no
big mistake zach yeah you shouldn't have
been big
oh my god hey everybody relax i would
have talked to you off the ledge no
artificial flavors oh that's good
oh god
only 140 calories um
[Applause]
okay back in
okay so the tweet's over i gotta i gotta
you know what i gotta take this from you
are we all stuff ringers it's just me no
no i'm not feeling okay
i already filmed the entire thing i
already read that 10 golden [ __ ] grain
sema
it's time to heal
come on the show where were we right
we're talking about christmas specials
see you come on the show it's time to
heal oh god oh my god i can't for a
second
everyone
what daschle can you come in and host
well the gist of this segment how are
you talking right now i i think i'm i'm
like uh i've like left my body
and like i'm just
running trying to catch up with it
oh
or just hit the top of my mouth um so
we're gonna pitch
other also credit to simu again come on
the showman man
that was a funny tweet yeah i know he
got he got a lot of backlash online
because people are still kind of hurt
about the background thing you know it
was too soon
that was a funny joke that was a good
good play on words you know what simu we
support that type of humor around here
and we'll make fun of people with you
come on on simu let's mock everyone
here's what i want from you guys
everyone give me their best cancelled
holiday special and guess what i know a
guy down at t michael films that can get
stuff made oh we'll reinvigorate the
franchise or whatever you're doing who
wants to go first
i'll go okay all right so simu we see
you with the good ass jokes yep
i wanted to put that in there zach
aholism
you statement oh god no god all right
i'm just gonna say this
what i wanted to say his okay
i want john you to say yours okay zach i
want you to say yours but when it's time
for me to share mine
i'm putting a mouthful of pocky chips
here
i'm there with you i'll do the replays
with you during the time we're getting
close to having to make count time oh my
gosh
wait what was the bar set 100 bucks 700
bucks for leading the [ __ ] and by the
way we said we lady in the trash
you're the one that you're you're adding
in a little bit of i figured there's
going to be some lips touching
for a penny and for a pound as i'm gonna
say all right so the holiday special
that probably get canceled but it isn't
real uh war machines winter wonderland
whoa
yeah because i want to see him do some
stuff i don't know what i'm doing is
coming out yeah machines went to
wonderland that's sweet i like that a
lot of w's
i'm gonna throw out there
one of my favorite recent christmas
films
the christmas switch
franchise yeah vanessa hutchins
um you can just move one letter in that
yeah and it becomes the christmas witch
and it's about it's about a young woman
with uh wild omega level powers yeah who
just wants to find love for the holidays
okay
uh is it with this uh white version of
the guys you used to love probably not
will it be with uh you know the the
handsome guy who owns a mansion in uh
rural england maybe i don't know you
know it's like she's gonna say once you
go white yeah that's all right i don't
need that oh god no no uh what's your
report wrapping up outside
uh here's what i want to do we're
watching we're we're
we're all over the holidays we're
sitting around the camp no that's not
how the holidays work we're sitting
around the fire with our families you
don't go camping on christmas i don't
tend to we put on the we put on the
newest lifetime movie with their family
and friends we're all sitting around
watching it
suddenly we were sort of like oh that
was weird did you like hear an explosion
way back from the mix there i just want
to see
the hawkeye series but from a street
level perspective of like the the woman
who works too hard who like couldn't
make it home for christmas a single mom
that works two jobs
um and that's what i want to see i want
to see i want to see yeah she's trying
to take her kid ice skating yeah
rockefeller and there's all these
explosions
or just shoot it up yeah
exactly yeah yeah that's what i want all
right can i see the pockets i'm gonna do
mine now i don't as somebody whose mouth
is still vibrating in pain i don't
recommend that tommy but i will join you
with the
the carolina reaper cheetah graveyard 50
3503 saying howard the holoduck special
oh that's a nice one graveyard i think i
haven't already done film juice zach put
this towards your co-pay
also from jesus we're done with you
harassing us
i heard mom oh no
oh no no
i know how bad this is going to hurt you
oh wow okay okay here we go we're all
doing it
also deals with an explosion
i'm leaving the mcu oh no
and groggy hbo max
well we still have it that might not be
a great place to hang out
and for what i like to present
chernobyl i'm screaming of a white
christmas oh my god
a musical
retelling it's a musical
of the greatest nuclear gas degree in
the history of the world it hurts to
breathe
the chernobyl explosion just like
chernobyl go through song
dance
and gorgeous animation by the geniuses
who brought you pixar's cars too
chernobo i'm screaming of a white
christmas we'll have you sing
maybe we shouldn't do christmas this
year
uh on that on that note um
i feel like that's a great place to end
yeah thank you tommy with complete
nuclear annihilation which is exactly
what i feel in my mouth right now well
what i'm about to feel from my south
pole
turn your mouth to your south pole oh
god yeah a lot of my heat is like is
already kind of in the lower uh the
lower abdomen level if you keep shoving
them into your mouth you never found
pain you know what thank you everybody
for watching
um
i disagree okay thank you thank you for
the non sadists watching um the four of
you that donated over fifty dollars for
fifty dollars plus
shame on you shame um we're back the
rest of the week and you know what no no
more eating challenges this week uh
frankly we're gonna need seven days to
recover um we're back the rest of the
week we'll be talking all kinds of uh
news and notes we didn't even get to
talk about i watched prey on hulu over
the weekend did you see that yeah well
we might talk about prey later in the
week there's also a little tug of
maverick news out there there's some
other stuff um all of that leading into
next week when of course we get she-hulk
uh premiering on the roof coming out on
wednesday i am groots coming out this
week yes we'll be talking about that
this week uh lots of fun uh in store for
us in these dog days of summer
get on our tick tock i'm gonna i'm gonna
post some aftermath of this episode on
our tick tock so go follow us over there
do it up oh yeah yeah [ __ ]
i have literal tears in my eyes
don't wipe don't wipe with your fingers
keep it gucci to moochie